no no no I she stopped the video and
they restarted check us out check us out
take us out guys oh I turned that
perfectly it's a its death battle in a
cosplay video Oh
but their trailer came out and I I am I
still stand by my belief that that
Marvel's gonna do sword that like
they're gonna do they're gonna tease
sword and and I feel I feel like they
should
his Carol Danvers runs floored right now
even less is kind of not really part of
it although she kind of is I'll even
though she's still running sword anymore
it was ever gonna brand back in the day
but you guys who don't know sword stands
for sentient world observation and
response Department what does that mean
they're basically shield but they
monitor space instead of earth and uh
and this and it's kind of cool um I mean
there's not a whole lot more from this
trailer than what we saw before but it
is it is kind of cool like the outfits
like I made through those Avengers
office like amazing those vintage dolls
were pretty badass and it is pretty
exciting like it really it really is
exciting to see the whole thing go down
although I will say this I think I think
they're gonna reboot a couple characters
like I think they're gonna reboot
Captain America and and I am an all
talking to him are I about this this
morning and it was like okay cuz okay so
in the trailer okay so in the trailer
like Peggy Carter is talking and I see
which is like a memory flashback the
Peggy Carter is talking and she's like
sometimes all you can do is start over
so I'm just like there it is so like
they're basically get like I think
they're gonna I look like a reboot
Captain America or Ironman but I think
they're gonna write them out like
they're gonna good okay here so here's
the thing alright here's kind of the
question that I've been asking this is a
question I was asking this one this was
one in this one what is the moment in in
Avengers 4 when Doctor Strange
told Iron Man he said I'm sorry Tony but
it was the only way
what if it had nothing to do with him
giving up the time stone like what if
what if it had nothing to do with him
given the time stone up and giving it
the famous because by that time pretty
much everybody was gone except for like
nebula and I think rocket and like that
was it
and so everybody else was essentially
like what's relevant the purpose is just
like Dustin and so what if Iron Man
doing that is missing like hey look man
like because here's the thing if dr.
strange looked into the future and and
he saw every possible outcome in terms
of like of whether or not they would
defeat Thanos it means he would have to
know like the the consequences for that
outcome right like he'd have to know
what would happen after that right so
like in one scenario they defeat Thanos
and then like Galactus shows a result I
don't know something crazy but like he'd
have to know what the consequence of
committing that act was gonna be and if
it's every possible scenario then that
includes like time travel right like the
Avengers go back in time and they
stopped Thanos where they they do
something in like the whole timeline
gets screwed up and so it could simply
just be one of those things where like
they have to go all the way back so like
some some point in the distant past and
they defeat Thanos but then to like
divide the questions asked like what do
we do next well then I managed to us
asking questions like what my parents
didn't die and Captain America starts
asking questions like well what if what
if like I never always never frozen in
ice and so you literally wipe them out
by having Tony start basically say like
having it having him done such a way of
where the Winter Soldier never killed
Howard a Maria stark there for Tony
Stark never became the head of Stark
Enterprises when he did and like Howard
is still running the whole show
which means Tony Stark is doing whatever
Tony Stark is doing and then you have
Captain America who has never frozen
eyes he's written now because he's like
an old man now basically like the Super
Soldier Serum is worn out because of
Marvel Comics it does wear out like
after like it's like the Infinity
formula of Nick Fury right like after a
while it will just run its course and
then it won't work anymore so like we
know that from know that was no wait a
minute House of M House of M Steve
Rogers never got the super-soldier
formula what story was that we're like
Captain America where he grew old after
the Super Soldier Serum ran its course
not that not that but not the Rick
Remender run where he lost the super
soldiers here but those one with a Super
Soldier Serum ran of course he basically
got old and like he aged no maybe but it
was like Earth 98 that one were like
like you know heroes aged in real time
but regardless of the situation like you
basically write them out that way and
then attorney just kind of go forward
and whatever happens happens but I do
there's so many weird things because
like like we know that's fine
and far from home takes place after
Avengers in game presumably black
panther 2 takes place after Avengers in
game as well and so like there's no real
reference there like that there's like
no one for them aware for the trailers
that we've seen no one references in
game and the trailers are not like the
movies right so like it's like we went
and sat down and watch the whole like
far from home movie and then speaking of
movies it's not like we saw the whole
far from home movie and like you was
never referenced once or anything like
that like just based on the trailer but
you would think there would be some kind
of statement like man dude good thing we
escaped that [ __ ] by the skin of our
teeth
Mariah Mariah don't forget we're here to
go see us today yeah okay um but yeah
like like I mean it's it's it's it's
like I mean you would think there would
be some kind of a reference there but
it's some of a far as I'm aware there's
not which means that maybe nobody
remembers it and if nobody remembers it
then what we're looking at is like some
some secret wharves 2015 slash House of
M type stuff
what is entirely possible because that's
usually what always happen in Marvel
Comics whatever there was some kind of
like universe shattering event or
something like that some [ __ ] popped off
things took place like during the
original Infinity Gauntlet story when
everything was fixed nobody remembered
like for the most part well I'm like
like it was literally let the conflict
end and like everything was set back to
the way it was before the events of
Infinity Gauntlet took place so like
half no one was it uh like like Adam
warlock was just like undo everything no
I'm sorry I think was nebula who said
undo everything and basically like like
with the accession of the heroes who
were there nobody remembered like nobody
on earth remember that had happened and
so it's like okay like you could easily
pull that off and just say like like the
whole event concludes about whatever man
or whatever means and like nobody
remembers it it took place nobody
remembers getting dusted or anything
like that where the exception of like a
handful of different people but that's
the issue is Avengers for like like
Marvel's lizards literally come out
instead of interest for supposed to set
the stage for everything that comes
after and so it wouldn't make any sense
to have a movie that like that that's
supposed to set the stage for everything
that ends in such a way that nobody
remembers what happened because then
what's the motivation for setting the
stage after that like the whole basis
behind sword is literally like like the
way I would do it I would say okay so
like we had the invasion of New York we
had like the okay
no you still got okay so you can still
do the invasion of New York you still
say okay so nobody remembers infinity
war
I'm sorry yeah nobody members the events
of infinity war Avengers 4 that was all
basically undone right like the movie
happened and then it got reset and so it
was like the movies never happen and so
then what you do is you say that like in
the aftermath of the attack on New York
by Loki that that the federal government
creates a branch off called sword and
they bring in Captain Marvel to run it
but here's okay here's what I think
here's what I think would actually
happen like yours here's my perspective
what would actually happen uh in reality
I don't think I don't think any I don't
think anybody like I think anybody wins
like I think I think that the events
happened half the life in the universe
is wiped out and they can't undo it like
there's there's no way to bring back
half the people who died with the
exception of the superheroes and maybe
they just like travel to the Past like
they sit down and they realize that
there's no way to get these superheroes
like there's no way to save these
superheroes so like we can't bring back
like spider-man we can't bring back
these characters so there's some
time-travel shenanigans and they grab
them from the past to bring them to the
present and say okay now we basically
have them back like because what that
what that would do is it would let
Marvel because I mean we know
time-travel events are gonna be part of
Avengers four it would let Marvel bring
back the Avengers who died the ones that
people care about anyway but it would
allow them to bring back the Avengers
who died while keeping half the universe
dead because it wouldn't make any sense
to say like hey we're gonna undo
everything except for like all the
innocent people like we're only gonna
bring back the superheroes because you
know reasons like it doesn't you you you
can't really do that it wouldn't really
make any sense to the average viewer but
some time to have a shenanigans would
make it work and so that that would
explain why you have Peter Parker that
would explain why you have like Panther
all that kind of stuff
I think that Angela Bassett said that
Sheree and like black Heather's mom
survived like they live through the snap
so so I mean I don't know like I'm kind
of curious to see what happens like it's
gonna be awesome regardless like I'm
excited for the movie but the costumes
look badass but the costumes look look
friggin sweet like I'm I'm pretty hyped
for that whole thing again like I still
say okay so for the most part like I've
got a working theory on how you bring
the x-men end right I mean they're like
I've got that like I'm not that Theory
pretty much locked down so I'm not
really worried about that my question is
a Fantastic Four how do you bring the
Fantastic Four Han because assuming like
all this happens right like assume that
all this stuff happens right Lee all
these all these super okay I feel like
everything happens on the superhero so
on so forth like Avengers 4
and however it ends it doesn't matter
whether they remember whether they don't
doesn't really matter but in the
aftermath like somebody somewhere like
Nick Fury says he looked like you know
let's go explore space like the athlet
you basically act like nothing
world-shattering happened except for the
invasion of New York with like in the
original Avengers movies so like famous
liver snap your fingers half the lights
the universe never died
technically infinity war and Avengers 4
never actually happened depending on how
they how they do the whole thing so then
what you do is you say okay so they've
got sword and then II kind of fan has to
core into it because here's the thing
that people get hung up on and right now
that the Marvel Cinematic Universe is so
far from the comics that it's almost not
even funny they were the exception of
the characters there's not really any
relation there right like technically
speaking of Marvel Comics Stannis is
immortal like he's supposed to be
immortal I guess he's not now cuz his
head was chopped off and he was a
floating spirit just kind of making his
way around but technically speaking
Pharaohs was supposed to be immortal he
was banished from the realm of mistress
death he was never allowed to enter
that's why when the multiverse collapsed
when everything died Thanos was just
kind of stuck out in the Bolivian he
couldn't die like that that was that was
one of the big points one of the things
that was remembered recalled by Jeff
Lemire I think during the original
Thanos wins so it's kind of cool because
it's like okay because technically stand
out like ten moon fellas was dying he's
not supposed to be able to die I don't
know it's it's one of those things we're
like events like that kind of get
forgotten and so it's just you know the
left handed know what the right hands
doing but anyway what you do is you say
okay so the only earth-shattering event
that's happened after the events of
Avengers 4 and like infinity war in
Avengers 4 because some time travel
shenanigans happen they did the Avengers
did some stuff they won but technically
the events of those movies never happen
because of how the Avengers won the only
earth-shattering event that ever took
place where the vendor's was the
original Avengers movie when there was
the alien invasion so Nick Fury recalls
Carol Danvers she basically he's like
hey look we're gonna launch sword so
you're basically gonna like leave this
organization that's going to monitor
space rather you're gonna monitor space
and everything that's out there check
out the various threats so on and so
forth which you may have already been
doing but like you say okay swords there
and then what you say is we need a team
of people who are going to explore space
so like the Fantastic Four basically
stow aboard a ship they fly into space
they get hit with some cosmic rays they
come back and they got all their powers
done and done people get hung up on the
idea that the Fantastic Four should be
there before everybody else leave almost
you have to find a way to like throw
them in there like we just never knew
they existed but anyway you don't really
have to but you don't really have to do
that it'd be kind of cool if you did but
you don't really have to um but like
that's the way that you build a
fantastic for him and learn to say okay
like they have their powers now and then
just go forward from that but I don't
know I mean I'll be honest guys it
really is a crapshoot there's like
nothing coming out of Marvel for
Avengers 4 it's like literally the only
thing I don't care what anybody tells
you IGN bleeding cool like all those
different websites like all the
information they come down to like
here's everything we know about Avengers
4 basically like like don't read those
articles because all it comes down to is
like a thing is happening that's
basically all it is they don't know
anything like nobody knows anything like
its clickbait so I don't read those
articles all right they're full of
hoo-hah juice but but no it's it's it's
crazy like it's kind of nuts right now
but I don't know anybody what you guys
think uh and yeah I will catch you all
later firs